un cambio significativo en la política
antidrogas de colombia con la llegada
del nuevo gobierno el país andino
suspendió su estrategia de erradicación
de cultivos de coca la materia prima
para la producción de cocaína bajo la
idea del presidente colombiano gustavo
petro quien aseguró que la guerra contra
las drogas ha fracasado la casa blanca
aseguró que el presidente estadounidense
joe biden también le da la bienvenida a
una nueva era en la política de drogas y
el presidente parte es consciente que
muchas de las políticas del pasado han
marginalizado a algunas personas y ha no
han trabajado para muchas poblaciones y
lo podemos hacer mejor la administración
bain es una que está en una nueva era
sobre la política de los que es
holística
washington invertirá 2 millones de
dólares en el nuevo programa de
asesoramiento de drogas para un proyecto
destinado para los próximos 3 años el
gobierno de gustavo petro se
concentrarán a interceptar los
cargamentos de cocaína y planea ofrecer
incentivos a los productores de la hoja
de coca para que adopten cultivos
legales por una política de prevención
en el consumo en las sociedades
desarrolladas
es hora de una nueva convención
internacional
que acepte que la guerra contra las
drogas ha fracasado rotundamente
los anteriores gobiernos colombianos han
intentado erradicar los cultivos
ilícitos con la ayuda de soldados
herbicidas y drones y aunque esos
programas de erradicación de coca
también recibieron apoyo financiero y
técnico de washington según informes de
eeuu los cultivos de coca en colombia se
han triplicado en la última década